you fear birds you know you look like a
guy who wouldn't hear anything but you
fear birds why birds I was that call I
went to Oklahoma State University and I
was at summer school once and I'm riding
my bike and I had an afro at the time it
was before the male pattern baldness I
mean you see the hairs going here Hills
going on top and I had an afro and these
two birds came off the power line
they were like nesting my hair while
you're on a bike Waldman whoa
temporarily on the bike because I turn
quick and fell right so now you see this
this College wrestler all-american on
the ground picking up his books while
these two birds they're fearless they're
right behind my hair and they're trying
to nest my afro right and since then
they just freak you out
I almost ruin our family vacation last
week last year in Hawaii because my wife
Selena was for some reason she would not
move the food you know when you're on
these like those those chairs those
chairs yeah and these birds just kept
coming up to the I'm like move to move
to move to food Selena she's like it's
just a bird why are you so afraid of a
bird of life you have no idea what I
went through this right the first time
she's heard the story here's what I'm
gonna do Mayers what I'm gonna do the
time when you and I do fight and we will
I'm gonna come into the ring and you're
gonna approach me and I'm just gonna
open my arms and doves are gonna fly out
all over you yeah then you hate then
that belt will be yours and rightfully
so
you